ce sont les 25 ans du salon du chocolat
et pour cette soirée inaugurale un
défilé de robes en chocolat est organisé
par ton dans les coulisses les exposants
terminent leur dernière installation sur
leur stand du chocolat sous toutes ses
formes des oursons des tablettes mais
aussi des créations en chocolat
le salon du chocolat est international
il regroupe vingt pays producteurs je me
trouve actuellement dans les coulisses
33 vont être portés et présenté lors de
cette soirée inaugurale les créateurs
s'affairent pour peaufiner les derniers
détails de ces êtres en prob avec des
thèmes différents
dans les coulisses des créations parfois
surprenantes comme celle ci avec un
oiseau la gourmandise et l'art
s'entremêlent elizabeth tchoungui va
porter la robe en chocolat réalisées par
une équipe de trois artisans réunis par
la reine astrid
je retrouve nicolas morin de la reine
astrid qui s'est occupé de la partie
chocolat pour cette robe alors justement
parlez moi un petit peu de cette robe
qui va être portées par la journaliste
franco camerounaise alors déjà cette
robe on a voulu c'est de mettre en avant
ce qu'on peut retrouver au cameroun est
d'aider des idées des l'esprit un peu
comme on est donc on a travaillé des
matières brutes et des matières peu plus
dorée on a voulu à travers cette robe
montrer un petit peu la partie chocolat
mais la partie brut du chocolat
elizabeth tchoungui se prépare à enfiler
cette création une fierté pour elle
c'est avec beaucoup d'émotion et de
plaisir que j'ai accepté ce défilé parce
que la reine astrid travaille avec des
cultivateurs de cacao du cameroun or mon
père est camerounais mon grand-père
cultiver le cacao est donc c'est une
vraie fierté pour moi de porter
aujourd'hui les couleurs du cacao que
mes cousins continue de cultiver dans le
village de mon père
l'ouverture du défilé s'est faite avec
le groupe kalema deux frères originaires
de sao tomé et principe et lille cacao
le salon du chocolat mais les pays
producteurs à l'honneur avec des robes
en chocolat
on se retrouve sur le stand de la reine
astrid juste après le défilé d'elizabeth
tchoungui
ce sont des mois de préparation
satisfait du résultat mais satisfait oui
mais c'est beaucoup de préparation la
braderie on le voit pas mais c'est 200
heures de travail donc c'est un truc
énorme comme la reine astrid 229
exposants sont présents pour la 25e
édition du salon du chocolat